我的中文名字叫安征超然后英文名没有就是给哈贝个id叫over to your屏幕上这个id基本上在所有的社区和只要这个id没有被占用的情况下基本上都是我那这次讲的这个话题呢是怎么从零开始做一个开源项目因为实际上我们最开始的时候是打算讲就是做后段但是我个人一方面是我觉得我们现在
就是在云浮这么发展的阶段做后端其实有点像大鸡目一样没有太多的东西可以讲另外一方面就是公司有一些规定就是对于项目的一些细节是没有办法去对外公开讲的东西所以在后来我们就商量了讲这么一个话题是讲开源项目因为在我
工作这么多年的过程当中包括招的一些实习生或者一些新手他们都会有一个疑惑就是我一直没有去做开源家是因为我不知道怎么去下手去做所以呢我觉得讲这个话题可能会更具有朴射性一些那作为在给哈布混了差不多九年的一个人来讲呃我给哈布目前上有一百多个项目但是
大于五百新的可能就十几二十个不到总的大数大概是两万六应该是然后最火的一个项目可能大家都有的是听说过就是是一个PURP的第三方微信SDK叫做EZVChat然后呢我也是国内Larvo最也不算最早的那一批吧从4.2开始用但是呢那个时候是没有社区的所以在我和Summer两个人的
交流过程当中我们蒙发了一个将做一个中国社区的这么一个想法所以我们就将最前身叫做PV Hub然后最后变成Laura China一直到现在变成Laurenku这后面的故事就挺多的大概就是目标很简单就是希望能在PVP这些开发者当中更多的去推广Laura这个框架因为它真的是太优秀了另外我们这个公司我在目前在CDC就是腾讯的一个用户体验就与实际部
在这个部门当中负责项目叫做code design它今天在群里边差不多已经交流过了就是一个设计协作平台一会儿我讲完了以后再给大家发一下这个网址或者说是有知道的同学也在屏幕上打一下就好了这里不打广告所以就简单地提一下再做一个开源项目其实说起来简单它也非常的难就是全是细节我大概会通过八个部分去介绍
怎么去做一个开源项目那实际上做开源这件事情不仅仅是自己去做一个开源项目因为做开源这件事情有非常多的方向去参与比如说你帮别人修一个bug那也叫参与开源你帮别人改一下文档对吧帮他改一下错字那也算是参与开源那甚至呢你在用一个
工具的时候或者SDK或者一些包的时候发现了问题帮它反馈问题那也叫参与开源所以参与开源的方式有很多而不仅仅是创建一个就是以自己的名义创建一个开源项目你可以去充分的参与别人的项目因为自己做一个项目是非常困难的因为很多人会觉得说没有那么难我不就是建一个项目把代码放上去就好了吗那这个其实仅仅只是开始真正想要做好一个项目的难度是非常大
第一部分是我们今天讲的就不讲去修bug写文大部分而是讲一个你真正打算从零开始做一个项目就是以你的名义创建一个开源项目你应该怎么去做首先我们肯定是需要寻找创意来源但是这里先泼一个冷水就是如果你是为了做开源而去做开源就是因为我明天就做开源项目所以我现在想去找个创意那这个方向就错了
因为实际上真正很多优秀的开源项目都不是从零开始说我要做一个开源项目而去创建一个空项目这么做下来的大部分的情况都是通过他们自己的已有的项目当中的实践提炼出来的一个部分然后再将它不断的优化开源出来的所以方向一定不要搞错就是你不能为了做开源而去做开源这样的话你一定做不好的相信我这个绝对是正确的你绝对会做不好的因为
你没有充分的场景去体验和挖掘各种需求和痛点对所以屏幕上有人说的好就是因为你最好的场景就是从你实际参与的或者说你在工作当中的一些项目中遇到的痛点而产生出的一些工具或者说是一个可以开源的项目这才是一个更适合开源的东西所以方向上一定要做好我们刚才强调了一定要从项目中去提取那你说我
做的像本来就很简单或者实在没有一些很好的想法那怎么办呢你肯定参与过很多的交流群对吧就比如说咱们今天的这些交流群那一定会有人在群里问问题那这些问题可能有一些东西是有已经有一些工具来解决的还有一些问题是没有现成的东西和方案来解决那这个时候呢你就可以考虑去把他们的这些需求提炼出来做一个项目
因为你是从需求出发的但是在这个过程当中还是建议自己去先把自己当作用户去实践最后一个就是社区因为刚才讲的那种及时交流的消息一般都不可追溯可能一天或者一会不划就看不见了所以在社区上其实是有更容易发现这类需求的地方举一个最简单的最有用的地方就是各种开源项目的e-show比如说那些比较火的项目它的那个
一球列表你绝对是一大把大把的然后里边肯定有很多问题没有解决如果你有空你又想去研究这个项目那你就从解决这些问题开始在解决的过程当中你可能会遇到问题比如说你提了MR这个作者又不愿意或者说这个项目已经很久没有人维护了但是用的人还挺多这个时候你就fock他基于他去做一些改进于是就产生了你的开源项目当然这里面还有一个开源协议的问题我们后面再讲
第一部分是創意来源第二部分是你真正开始动手了那真正开始动手那实际上也并没有那么容易因为我们都知道我们将代码放在github上面有成千上万的甚至上百万的人可能会看到你的项目那这个东西就会代表着你的面子你就不应该出现一些低级的错误对吧命名的用拼音混合过着各种奇葩的一些显示
不同意的规范等等那比如在我们PAP当中我们通常都建议做一些最基本的要求比如说代码规范对吧在PAP当中有个非官方的规范就是PSR这个项目组做的它有一系列的规范PSR1、PSR2、PSR1直到十几那这些规范的都是为了完善都是为了约定大家在这个项目当中去怎么去写一份大家能够互相都能看得懂的代码
所以我們在開源項目之前最好是需要把自己的代碼寫的合格在我們PAP當中我經常會用的一些工具比如PAP-CIS還有CBF還有PAP-ND還有一些開源的服務這個Style-CI現在已經不開源了包括在Gatehub現在新出的Action裡面也有很多自動化的工具可以去幫我們做另外還有這個
scruntinizer这个工具它也是个在线的解析服务就是你把你的开源项目集成进去它就可以帮你发现一些很多问题那最后还有一个travis CI这个也是做单元测试的在github上面专门有一个内幕来做这些工具的介绍叫做integrations大家可以去稍后我们会把这个PVT分享给大家那把代码写好了就可以放上去了吗其实不是的你要充分的测试很多人在
工作或者在自己的项目中其实我从我这么多年的经验来讲我觉得可能不到10%的人会去给他的代码写测试我这里的测试包括了一些基本的比如说手动的基层测试还有一些代码教本的测试所以我发现很多人包括在我之前的一些公司都是这个样子就是写代码是不写测试的那结果就是
测试同学忙饭天然后呢最后还是上线还是会有很多问题所以最好的想要把你的代码写得更好的方案就是你自己写测试用力用自动化的脚本代码测试或者集成测试各种工具去保证你代码的健重性因为你在写这个测试的过程当中你就会发现一个问题就是你代码很难测试那这个这种情况的时候基本上你的代码就写得不够好那所以如果你的
测试写得不是很困难的话那证明你的代码还是不错的那这个观点呢实际上你没有去试的话你可能赞同就是你你可能觉得我都写了十几二十年了你说我代码写不好那是不可能的那最简单的测试标准就是你自己去用derry unit或者是各种工具去写一遍测试用力你就知道你的代码写得好不好了呃我们测试有很多方方面啊比如说单元测试和功能测试等等那
我们除了写以外还要知道怎么去写那比如说我们有一个计算器的代码那我可能会去测加法减法成法出法但是你没有必要把一个加法测n变对吧所以呢你只需要把一些每个边界都测试到就行了所以正确的写用力也是一个问题我刚才看到公平上有人说就是没有时间写测试呃这个呢其实我有一个观点就是
首先我们的项周期其实程序员是或者说工程师负责这个模块开发的人是有一定的话语权的对吧不可能说产品经理说我明天就要上线那你就一定明天上线那你你不可能写的完的情况下怎么办呢对吧他总不能让你每天26个小时嘛所以我们在预估公期的时候呢给自己留一点控育的事情那然后呢就是
你觉得你很紧张所以导致你没有时间写测试那最后的结果就是你上线以后你还是会把很多时间划来修bug就是总的这个时间是几乎很定的就是如果你的测试用力写得很缺你代码很健重那你的bug就会出现得少你修bug的时间就会少那自然而然你总的时间是没有太大的区别的那甚至有时候呢我们会发现写测试的时间比写原代码的时间还要多
那这个是很正常的然后呢另外一个观点就是工作当中确实去很难平衡这个时间这个我是非常认可的因为在尤其是在某一些技术并不被公司所特别看重的公司的话这个是更困难的那所以说呢我只是建议争取啊因为这个时间是就总时间是很定的在这种前提下呢尽可能的去让自己有这个写测试的时间当然
这里面还有一个条件就是如果你前期不熟悉写测试那你前面花的时间是非常多的还有就是有人说你测试用力并不能找全所有Bug是的没有问题确实是这样任何一个行为都不能保证百分百的覆盖所有的场景但是呢它可以解决大部分基础的逻辑或者说是一些场景错误因为你只要测试边界都到位的话那可以解决80%的问题另外一方面就是
我这里我们主要讲的是开源所以说在工作场景当中如果你解决不了那你就在做开源项目的过程当中参与别人开源项目的过程当中去练习自己写测试的这个能力当你写测试的这个速度越来越快以后可能在工作当中写测试的时间也就不需要那么多了当然这个是需要长期磨练的一个过程在我们写测试当中我们需要关注一个覆盖度
所有的這些測試工具幾乎都有這個功能那以前我們在微博的時候我們的要求是達到95%的覆蓋度那這個覆蓋度呢有航覆蓋度還有方法覆蓋度還有類覆蓋度所以我們基本的要求是達到航覆蓋度的95%這個呢其實還是蠻容易做到的但是前期呢就是對於不同尤其是人多的團隊這個訓練成本是蠻高的但是在開源項目呢大部分是在前期都是單打獨鬥所以說呢你可以充分地去
想怎么玩另外就是我们的测试一定是要可以自动化跑的你人工的测试那些其实都没有太大的意义当然我说的不是手工测试没有意义是对于开源项目这种需要大量的测试的场景的情况下我们是需要用自动化的当然如果你用这些开源的工具肯定都是带自动化测试的那这里主要强调的是说比如说我们尽可能的要用这些免费的
测试工具比如说 GitHub下面有个 GitHub Actions当你每次提交以后它会自动的去帮你跑测试然后在本地的话你也可以用 Gatehooks来实现当你提交之前做一遍测试等等这些方案具体细节在每一种不同的项目当中有不同的解决方案大家可以去网上再去找一找当我们的代码写完了以后我们是这个项目想要去推广用的话我们一定要写一份非常好的文档
那如果你的项目是给全球用户就是不筛选国际的那你尽可能的提供中文和英文两个版本你不用担心你的英文不够好现在有很多的工具都翻译的特别精准那比如说最近比较火的一个叫做deepl.com那他们的翻译就几乎和我们的没有太大的错误问题比谷歌翻译还要牛逼
那如果你的项目是给中国人用的或者说99%的都是中国人用的那你就没有必要去写一份英文了当然如果你最可能的写那肯定是比较优秀的了如果你觉得英文不好那你写中文的也没有什么问题就是另外一个就是提供在线文道因为我们除了写文道我们还需要一个在线文道有的我见过有一些项目他们的文道是需要加群去获取的而不是在
可以hub或者任何一个在线网站就能看到这个就会比较难受我们可以通过github的仓库直接在那个readme文件里面写如果你的项目够简单的话比如一个readme一页就能写完那你就直接写到readme上就好了那如果你的项目文档需要好几页去展示的话那你可以考虑使用githubpages这个功能那这个其实也非常的简单它默认就提供了
非常丰富的一些模板所以你只按照它的规则去填的话就可以做一份非常漂亮的文档另外你也可以考虑自建网站那自建网站的话一般文档型的工具就非常多了比如说我们最流行的前装空下view他们就出了官方的一个文档工具叫做view press对吧那最近还有个更新版本的叫做vite press那你都可以用这些工具去自己搭建一个简单的纯净态的网站
非常方便包括我刚才那个EZVX的那个项目也是用这个工具来搭的那另外一部分就是我们在这个内容里写什么东西那怎么样就写这个内容才叫做友好的文档相信各位也很见过很多那些开源项目的文档看了一遍你不知道怎么用对吧看完以后不知道他在说些什么因为其实很多程序员丝就是觉得
主动的会带入自己的上下文觉得说我都会用了我就按照我写的这些例子给它贴上去就可以了但实际上呢一定要注意这个问题就是很多使用者他并没有你的这个上下文所以他需要从零开始了解你这个是什么有什么优点各种都要列出来所以呢我们首先要把一些基本的状态给他列上去比如说你肯定看到很多概念像他的那个Ridemey上都有一些那种绿的红的那些标签对吧什么building status那些
构建状态等等那这些你可以通过这些标签看到这个项目是否还在维护构建式和成功最后的版本是多少目前的下载量是怎么样等等这些信息因为这个就玩得很花了有很多种可以展示的标签另外呢最吸引人的一点就是features还有它适用的人和环境要求因为你一个人决定用不用你这个项目它不可能花一天或者
半天来去试用以后再决定用不用你首先都没有抓住他的眼球的话他就不可能去用对吧所以我们在这顶上的部分就应该首先讲清楚我这个项目为什么会存在他有哪些特点哪些人可以用他对环境有什么要求对各种环境的版本各种工具的依赖是什么因为当人看到这一部分以后他就能在五分钟之内决定是否适合我
是否接下来去探索的这么一个必要性所以这个是非常重要的另外一部分就是介绍完优缺点以后就是使用实力和稳当那如果你是很简单的刚才讲了如果你是特别小的一个工具那就可能不需要一个单独的稳当地址那你只需要在这个页面当中列出一个基本的实力那这个实力你说它自己用不是更简单吗其实不是的因为
很多时候我们看一个项目用不用那个势力代码就是吸引人决定性的一个地方如果看到那个势力那个势力文档就觉得很秀比如说像Larva的文档一样每一段代码都看起来那么优雅那我觉得有必要去试一下所以我会接着往下看那当看到这里的时候实际上可能不适合的人很多人就已经放弃了就接着不看了可能看另外一个项目去了所以你一定要抓住眼球的就是
适合的人在这里还没有放弃每一步都是非常关键的那看完这个用力他可能就去试用去了那当有一部分人在用的时候呢他可能还要想参与维护那你的项目前期可能就不是很完善那第一批的用户可能在用的过程中发现一些问题那发现问题的时候应该怎么样向你反馈向你直接TMR要怎么样符合规范才能被合进去等等那这些规则就是贡献指南那一定要
把它列清楚说如果没有时间你有能力来帮忙我改进这个项目应该参照下面这种方法去参与贡献那你可以写些什么呢比如说你应该符合什么样的代码规范你应该使用什么工具去教研你的代码你应该玩怎么样玩跑测试怎么样写文档那最后TMR的时候标题应该怎么写等等那这些东西呢就是贡献值的
那如果你的贡献只能特别多的话你可以考虑单独写一个markdown文件然后再通过readme通过链接的设计到那个文件那最后一部分就是那个readme的下面的那个叶脚部分我们通常就是放一些就是授权就是我这个开源项目使用什么样的授权方案什么样的开源授权mit啊apachi absd啊等等各种这些授权的方案有很多种差别那你可以去在很多专业的网站都有介绍
那如果你的项目用了别人的项目或者是基于别人的项目改的甚至说有一些人给你提了好的介意或者说是你的这个项目是由谁的创意而产生的等等你所有需要感谢的人你都可以写到这里那最后呢下面的部分你就可以自由发挥了比如说写一些可能别人会用得到的一些链接或者工具等等比如说我这个工具可能需要搭配某个工具才能用你就把它写到下面等等那基本上这么一份文档下来呢
要用的人也找到了他想要的features对吧我因为想要这个功能想要这个特性所以我选择他然后我的环境也满足要求并且我看了实力确实符合我的习惯或者我的喜好等等最后呢想要贡献的人也能找到他怎么贡献那如果说你这些都不够的话那你可能就需要再放一个详细文档的地址那对手可能就需要一个官网对吧在把官网上把所有的每一个细节每一个API都列出来等等
好吧这部分有点重当我们把文档写完了以后你的项目必须要做第一个版本发布的那这个版本发布很多人会觉得说很容易吗1.0.0.0.0.0.0.0.几实际上我敢说可能有70-80%的人都不知道那三个数字就是那个版本号它的含义我在面试的时候基本上都会问这个问题就是版本号的含义基本上
只有九成的人都打不上来所以在发版之前我们需要了解一个概念叫做与一画版本与一画版本是个什么概念呢它实际上是一个公开的一个标准虽然它不是强制的但是目前的那些开源项目之类的都是在遵循这个标准的它有什么组成呢我们通常看到的版本就是三个部分一个叫做最前面的一位就是主版本号
次版本号和修订号,甚至在修订号后面还有一些字母,比如 beta, alpha,rc等等。那这个语化版本呢,它是由一个worldpress那个头像gavatas那个组织创办者,也是github的创办者来创建的,它有一个官网。
大家可以先一下再去看一下就是semantic version两个单词的前面三个字母切出来做了一个org的官网上面有各种语言的版本有兴趣的就去点开看一下接下来我们详细介绍一下这几个版本号的概念第一位这个肯定大家都会非常容易理解就是当你做了比较
大的改动我在面试过程当中所有人对这个解释的是当我觉得做大的改动我就变第一位做了中等一点改动我就变第二位做的小的改动就变第三位这个实际是不对的那这个主版版号只要你做了不兼容的API修改你就需要变第一位那什么叫做不兼容呢比如说你做了一个你当中有一个API是个方法调用以前是传两个参数第一个是整形第二个是数组
但是有一天你发现你的设计不合理你把第一个参数改成了伏点或者是传输组把它两个参数换了一下那这种就叫做不兼容的修改那我们专业的说法叫做break and change对吧破坏性变更哪怕你就改了一个字都叫做破坏性变更那这种情况下你就需要从1.0变成2.0
那你说这样感觉很没有必要确实是很没有必要所以我们通常的这种情况是不会去发大版本的那怎么办呢我们通常是做一个向下兼容就是在这个参数当中可能做一些兼容范围你可以喘两种类型然后在里面去if else再去消化这种小的修改所以通常主版版号的变化呢
确实和我们想象的差不多它是代表着做了很大一系列的改动那几乎就是重写或者是做了重新的重构这种情况呢我们才回去发大版本那刚才那种但是它的变化一定会代表就是破坏性变更就是几乎是不兼容的那这样呢在各种
包管理工具比如POP当中的包管理工具是composer那在其他元别就是js当中叫npm等等他们都会满足这个标准就是不会从1.0直接升到2.0那你说我怎么从1.0升到2.0这个一般的他会要求你手动升级前提就是你已经了解过我当前的代码是能从1.0升级到2.0了然后或者说你已经把你的业务代码改得支持了这个2.0版本这个时候你再去手动的改那个包
包生命文件当中慢慢号从1.0改成2.0才能更新主动update是没有办法升级的如果没有办法通过异服兼容的修改的话这个就只有是发大版本当然你可以攒一段时间把你的各种变更做了一堆以后攒成一坨了再去发一个大版本这样看起来就比较合理一点但是它的标志就是不兼容那次版本号又干什么呢
那次版本号其实它有一个标准就是它是兼容的首先比如说从1.1升级到1.2那后面还有1.0.0 1.1.0就是中间内位从1变成2或者2变成3的时候它其实是向下兼容那通常的情况就是我们在原来的基础上加了一些API或者加了一些代码甚至我重写了这个SDK但是呢对外暴露的API没有一点点的破坏性那这种情况下我们就发就会发第二个版本号
那在开源项目当中呢一般就是比如说有人给你贡献了一个MR新增了一个future那这种情况在旧的用户当中肯定是没有问题的那它也兼容所以呢这种情况我们一般就从1.2发到1.3这样子所以呢这是次版版那最后的修订版本号呢一般就是bugfix就是我们修各种bug肯定也是兼容的除了第一位后面两个都必须是兼容的那
一般就是修一些语法错误啊稳当啊或者说是重构代码呀等等所以这个是最后一位那我们变得最频繁的呢也是最后一位我曾经在做小程序开发的时候用到了一个UI框架就踩了一个非常大的坑呃他发了一个从2.2版本我用的是2.1然后呢我是周一的时候装的那个包然后把功能全部都做完那就发到了线上
然后发到线上呢我是中午发的所以这四天之内呢我也没有update这些版本等等就我就直接推上去了结果推上去以后当然那个年代呢对这个包管理工具的时候也不专业啊直接用了update这个命令那结果就是装到了2.2按理来讲从2.1升级到2.2是不会有任何问题的但是结果呢就导致我的小程序白平了你也知道这个白平是很难调的在GS小程序当中
是很难调试的那个时候的调试工具也不发达那我在本地怎么都付现不了直到我把整个项目删掉了重新装了一遍终于付现了
因为你本地的NodeModels是已经换成好了的就是装到周一的版本所以怎么都调试不出来最后把整个项目拧下山了从线上重新刻龙下来还再重新bill的终于发现了问题但是这个过程也是花了很久因为GS的爆错是非常不直观的尤其是编译以后它的爆错的位置和你真正出问题的位置是很难找的所以当我一步步的debug找到问题的时候我发现是我用的一个UI库它把那个夹载方式给盖了
你这加载方式改了就是完全用的方法都不一样所以就是破坏性变更了比如说我就找到这个作者我在英修当中给他反馈我说你从2.1发到2.2但是做了破坏性的变更然后他说我觉得就改了一行代嘛或者是改了一个文件我觉得说没有必要发大版本于是我就把这个1号版本的链接告诉他他那个项目当时已经有好几千star了就是非常火了
但是的结果就是他根本就不知道有这个异化版本的概念如果细心的你你可能会发现在github发版的那个页面就releases新建的时候那个版本号的那个页面的下面有一个链接其实就是这个异化版的链接并且在它的右侧就发版的页面的右侧是有一段文字说明的你需要遵循与异化版等等的但是很多人没有看过这个东西
那在修理号后面还有很多的一些延伸的一些符号比如说2C1、2C2、2C14等等那这些东西你就看着你的场景去用就好了当我们把版本发完了以后这个项目其实还没完因为你要怎么让你的项目被很多人知道要不要很多人用起来那这个其实也是有一个需要一定的技巧的我总结起来就是一句话让真正需要他的或说可能需要他的人
都知道它的存在那很多人会犯一个错就是加了一堆群为了推广这个项目加了一堆各种技术交流群爬爬爬跑到群里边贴链接结果不是被踢就是被骂对吧就非常的惨那这个当中其实你有很多的技巧首先你要确认这个群里的人是你这个项目的目标的受众然后呢你再不要那么生硬的去推广因为
實際上你只一旦發鏈接大部分的管理員都會直接幫你提掉了所以你可以開一個話題比如說大家什麼什麼都用什麼於是這個時候開始討論起來的我用這個我用那個大家覺得這個怎麼樣這是我寫的因為可能大家需要的這個時候你發出去是不是就不會被提因為你們有上下文你們在聊同一個話題那確實有這樣需要的人但是你如果跑到一個完全
不是打王者的群里发那你肯定是被提不管你怎么起话题都是要被提的所以一定要明白我这句话前半部分的内容让真正需要他的或者可能需要他的知道他的存在所以呢那这个的前提就是你的文档都写得非常好了然后他一看确实适合我想要的东西他才可能去接着去试用对吧那如果前面的工作权都没做好你推广的再机制也是没有用对吧所以呢要灵活的去想办法
那我还有一些技巧比如说你需要打响品牌那这个其实我是从14年还是什么时候开始的我给自己起了一个比较好记得给他的ID然后呢我做了一个卡通的头像我在所有的地方微博微信以及各种地方我都用这个ID所以只要有人看到这个ID肯定知道是我包括在游戏里面也是啊所以呢
不要随便的去改自己的头像和微信的ID等等那这个是个品牌的问题当然你可能前期还没有火的时候呢或者说还没有人知道你的时候呢到无所谓但是尽可能但是保持不动的话会更容易让别人记住那有些人我发现他的ID给他把ID一连串数字或者大小写加字母等等我是读了很多遍都记不住你说我怎么可能去记得下这个项目
当有人问我说超哥你没有用过什么样的图片采检工具啊这类的我突然就会想到我知道一个我能模糊的打出他的ID我去gap搜是不是就都能提高命中率对吧所以起一个很好的容易记住的ID以及保持这个品牌能让别人更加印象深刻另外就是要保持谦虚谨慎拒绝4B这个我承认我前期也做得不够好我之前在
知乎的时候经常去跟人私一些什么预言好坏的问题但是直到2016年的时候我就再也不参与这些话题的讨论我觉得没有意义因为有很多人比如有些是装睡的人有些是故意他就是要帛琉琉的人甚至有一些人他是不知道所以你怎么讲的没有意义因为他没有体验他没有去感受他没有经过这个过程所以你去跟他掰扯这些东西没有意义所以千万不要死一定要谨慎就是不管任何人骂你也好喷你也好
都谦虚一点这个确实是很难做到最简单的例子就是在那个github上面你的项目如果有人不会因为有一些人他确实太新手可能你的readme上没有去给他讲语言的基础没有给他讲你需要什么一步步的那种截图给他教结果就是他装不上或者因为他没有梯子结果装的时候抱错了然后就跑到医术里来喷人我就见过一个人抱我的那个gssdk里来喷说
你这写的啥玩意都跑不起来这玩意就该往K-Hop上面放还一千多星呢把我喷的我都不知道该怎么去回复这个事情很痛苦但是呢我就只是回复了一下说建议你看一下这个什么什么之类的就完事了就把它锁定了不想跟他聊了那另外呢就是选择专业的社区
不要去广杀网刚才讲的在各种群里发的肯定也是广杀网你可以去找到你这个语言或者说用你这个语言或者用这类工具比较多的一些社区然后呢去正面的去发而不是灌水灌水必然会被降泉甚至会被封号还是讲了一些技巧比如说我可以写一系列文章在中间去夹带私户对吧那如果你是非常非常有名气或者有一定影响力了以后呢
你这发这个软弯稍微硬一点问题不大所以就是选择对口的地方就是地方不要搞错了另外就是根据我的个人经验有一些不错的时间点第一个是周二为什么选周二呢因为周一很多人都在忙着擦屁股对吧周五还没干完呢或者突然周六日又提出了新的许久对到周一所以一般周一都会是开会又比较忙
然后周二可能刚好缓一缓那上午可能就溜达一下光光社区可能就看到了你的文章另外就是周三上午周三上午这个就是真正的一周的中间所以很多人也是没有那么稍微要优先一点点另外就是周五下午这个大家都懂了对吧周五就应该有周五的样子所以周五的下午大家都会比较轻松愉快所以我是个劳大工人然后周末就别动了周末千万不要浪费自己的时间
该休息休息该打游戏打游戏你去推广也没有任何量这个相信世国人都知道当然这个是我个人在我这个语言当中的一些经验啊背定通用大家可以去试一下另外就是讲的非常细的一点就是准确的表达我就发现很多人写软文他也不专业就是扯了半天呢都扯到话题上或者说这个方向怎么也能都引不过来最后声音的转到他的链接上这就别人一眼就能看穿所以呢一定要注意技巧
那通常呢就是先描述痛点对吧这个是最容易引起共鸣的我一旦把我和大家都可能遇到的一些问题发出来很多人对我也是这样我也是这样对我也需要这个我也需要那个然后接着就开始说对我为了解决这些问题呢我做了一个什么什么的工具它有这些特点一一支持批量支持自动支持什么什么把特点一堆吹出来适当的夸张一点没有关系啊
然后把它吸引住这时候它决定往下看最后就是正确的引导比如说这个工具是给什么什么用的有什么条件有什么要求和那个 rid me刚才我们讲文档那部分其实是差不太多的那这一部分搞定了以后最后就是你一定要留好反馈渠道和圈子
反过去就到Github issue以及文档当中也在每一个文档的末尾都需要留别人改文档的链接怎么去修改文字错误怎么反馈问题最好再建一些群或者是一些论坛有自己的一个圈子用户群交流群对吧把它们收到一起你才能发掘一些新的future的创意回到我们最开始第一页找创意天选打错了先不纠结这个问题
就是你有了这些群以后有些人在群里边反馈你才会发现你这个工具的不完美的问题那甚至肯定有喷子和打广告的这个你就自己想办法对吧那当有了反馈以后呢我们就需要去处理它那这个一般我的个人习惯就是我每天抽固定的时间来看比如说早上上班我一般到工位以后我前十分钟就是滑水就看看github看看问题那
如果有一些问题特别快你一分钟两分钟就能解决或者五分钟就解决那就顺手去把它修了那如果这个问题可能不是那么简单可能需要未来我花一周或者抽一个周末来搞先给他打个标签对吧然后呢再去制定那个改进计划再去抽时间把它改好就好了当然有一些bug的时候一定要修得很快这个是非常重要的因为你自己去找开源项目你都会去找这个标准就是看他的bug多不多所以呢有bug的时候一定快速地修啊
最后就是当你的项目已经开始有一定的用户了你的项目已经跑起来了有用户了那你这个时候呢就需要去保持活跃因为如果当你平常你自己去找一个项目你发现他的last update是一年前两年前你肯定是不会再用了对吧所以呢一定要保持更新那你说我没什么改的怎么保持更新呢改文档吧把文档写好一点帮别人解决的问题然后把一些代码重构一下
或者说是你如果你的项目真的活起来肯定会有很多问题所以不用担心这个问题就不用担心我找不到怎么更新除非你写的项目可能就两行单那确实不需要怎么更新所以在这个过程当中一定要去多从用户的反馈当中找到改进的计划当有人在区里说为什么没有这个功能能不能把这个加一下你就把这些列出来做一个改进计划然后做一个大版本那大版本就花周期长一点去做然后小版本就快速迭代
那小版本就是刚才讲的字版本好吗比如说我新增一些future那就可以可以在一周或者两周或者一个月就把它搞定那大版本的比如说我的ezywechat我的大版本基本上都是在七八个月甚至到一年这么一个周期才发一个大版本另外就是尽可能的写好change loft这个其实很难啊因为你尤其是你个人项目实际上
如果没有强制的一些工具和规范的话你说难做到这一点但是如果你提供了这一点的话会对你项目的好感都大大提升就是当有人从1.0升级2.0的时候他需要知道你这两个版本变了什么我需要怎么改才能兼容你这个版本所以说Change Log是非常重要的它并不是一个所谓的很多人会觉得说写这些东西其实是装的是为了显得你这个项目很正统其实真不是这样所有的问题都是从用户角度出发
需要能帮到用户那我要讲到这个怎么做开源项目的过程当中呢到这里基本就结束了所以说看起来我们原来所认为的做一个项目只是把代码开源出去这么简单所以听完你会发现其实并不是所以开源代码把代码开放出去真的只是非常简单的第一步后面最难的一点就是持续维护每次公司有人问我做开源最难的点是什么我说
就是坚持下去的动力一不正确二不没有各种利益的情况下你怎么去保持你这份初心去把这个项目一直的做下去这个才是最难的也是最有挑战的尤其是很多人还在那里喷你不尊重你的劳动果实还各种伸手挡等等那你在这些挑战下都不放弃的话那才是真正的算做好了一个开运项目
我相信我们很多人都见过或者是用过很多大厂的一些方轮子就是开源的时候吹的吹上天然后各个社区都去发文章最后用了两个月以后几百个千个英修都没有人管甚至出现了很多安全性的八个都没有人修那就是很惨你的项目已经用上了但是这个功能又没有目前没有新的可以替代所以就很尴尬你伤害的是用户所以其实间接的伤害的是你自己
所以最大的受害者是你自己那做好一个开源项目呢每一步都是非常重要的所以如果你想去做这件事情就一定要把每一步都做好一旦开了头就没有什么回头路当然你在没有用户的情况下回头还是来得及的好那我讲的内容就到这里那接下来就是如果有什么问题呢我们都可以一会再接着聊好谢谢大家